how much does it cost to get an
influencer to tweet about your doge elon
stupid ponzi coin
today we find out welcome to day four of
a coffeezilla christmas i'm your host in
the 10 million dollar studio now guys
ever since soja boy cranked that twitter
a little too hard and exposed that he
had been paid 24 000
um to promote cryptocurrencies aka safe
mars we've known that influencers are
making thousands the same way
influencers promote vpns or g-field
they've now moved on to crypto now i'm
not going to waste time explaining the
ethical and moral difference between
advertising blue chew and sticks yes
there is a difference but ultimately
like it or not influencers aren't going
to stop pitching the latest get rich
quick schemes and with regulation five
to ten years behind you guys are at risk
falling for
ads disguised as influencer posts so
today i thought i would share with you
guys all the secret lists i've found of
crypto influencers prices the price is
to post sponsored posts and many of them
do not disclose that they are sponsored
although some do now up first we have at
nft on instagram now this one is near
and dear to my heart because they are
apparently a mark cuban company and
leverage company you contact at jf for
business and yes we will but just
looking at some of their posts you can
see what kind of stuff they do december
6 i'm dropping my first nft eighth in
space we're going to the moon so don't
miss it here we have another uh shill
post uh another shell post and uh these
do not say that they are ads okay they
do not say that now of course i was
curious how much they charged so i asked
them how much do you charge for a post
and they say what's good we charge 20 to
25 000 per post which is part of a
campaign that includes a full feature
blood blah blah blah the point is 20 to
25 000
for a
undisclosed ad
which i just think is awesome coming
from a mark cuban company that's just
that's beautiful you know you'd think
that these are great projects that these
people believe in but actually
a bunch of it's paid now next up we have
a guy you may have heard of at bitboy
crypto he's the largest youtube crypto
channel and i found this media kit
thanks to zach on twitter who's always
digging up really interesting crypto
stories now here in this media kit we
can see the demographics of uh bitboy's
channel we can see that it uh it is
mostly uh gonna be a male audience which
not too surprising there but we can also
see how much it costs for you know
getting shouted out dedicated review
five thousand dollars live stream just
pay twenty thousand dollars you could be
in a live stream mention youtube
interview oh well that's gonna cost you
forty thousand dollars telegram ama oh
that's gonna be uh ten thousand dollars
and a website article only twenty five
hundred dollars guys just twenty five
hundred dollars you can be written about
by bitboy crypto now i reached out to
him to confirm this is real he did
confirm this is authentic pricing but
when i asked if he ever does a sponsored
post without disclosing he said
absolutely not ben armstrong always
discloses if it's a paid post but now we
know how much he's been paid there it is
uh forty thousand dollars you two can be
uh interviewed by bitboy crypto so i
think that's uh super exciting obviously
now up next is another find uh this is
from big step up marketing i'm just
gonna call this list the music slash
rapper slash has been actorless now
we're gonna have to break this down
because this is just it's amazing
up top we have the beginner tier list
this is if you're a baby project you
know you're you're a you're a starter
this is the starter cap project here
you've got people ranging from i don't
know eight thousand to ten thousand
dollars right here and you have people
like kyle massey aka corey in the house
you've also got legends such as wide
neck yes ladies and gentlemen you can
get wide neck to shout out your crypto
scheme and then um then going down we
have the mid tier so this is going to be
20 to 50 000
per post and as you can see this might
get you a soja boy the shiggy show
whoever that is that's if you're a
little more serious and then at the
bottom we've got the vip section this is
a hundred thousand dollars or more here
we go little pump starts at a hundred
thousand dollars you've also got dj
khaled over here for one million dollars
okay and you've also got a post malone
in the weekend coming in at the mid
hundred thousand so if you ever want to
buy these guys influence i guess that's
that's that's the price now bear in mind
this price list comes from the soul
celebs project uh and the reason i'm
saying that is because
anyone can put together just some list
of a bunch of famous people with prices
next their name right but in this case
the same project got sponsored posts
from some of these influencers and that
obviously lends credibility to this
list's authenticity because if they're
saying they can get these posts and then
they got some of them uh seems like
maybe it's real for example they got a
cory in the house to post about him they
also got soja boy aka big draco to post
about him they also got the shiggy show
to post about them i think he's since
deleted that post they just saw archive
stuff on instagram but i think it's
important to say whether they can get
you know uh rick ross or post malone
i don't actually know right sometimes
these marketing teams pad out their
influencer lists with really famous
people to seem like more credible than
they are so uh just take this list for
what it's worth while it seems that
definitely some of these are
authenticated some of them may not be we
don't know i think the real takeaway
here is just how cheap soja boy is only
25 000 and you can crank that okay just
so you guys know in case you're
wondering how much does it cost to crank
that hey it's 25k now last but not least
guys we have a price list also dug up by
zack on twitter go follow him okay get
some good stuff this is a set of twitter
and youtube influencer prices here's
twitter here from uh such legends as
crypto tony crypto liz liver coin girl
gone crypto you've also got youtubers
like journey chico crypto bit boy okay
and then you got their prices over here
now obviously some of them are more
expensive than others and uh this tells
you what your package includes some
people give you the full dedicated
review some people give you a sponsor
segment but either way you're gonna be
signing checks okay and this is just a
beautiful look behind the curtain of how
these operations work these educators of
crypto work now bear in mind this uh
this all comes this leak it comes from
these guys luna pr they call themselves
a global fintech pr agency focusing on
crypto now these guys actually addressed
this database leak they said in a
statement lunapr would like to take a
moment to address the situation
regarding our influencer database which
has been leaked this document has been
tampered with and included false
information we have never worked with
some of the influencers on this list
including ivan on tech so uh bear in
mind they did say that now i we gotta
unpack this a little bit because it's
interesting on the one hand they're
verifying their list did get leaked so
we know at least some of that's very
real and then they say some of it got
tampered with which we can't verify um i
will say it does seem like they have
incentive to save face for their clients
who might be embarrassed by appearing on
such a list with their prices on the
other hand i could also see lunapr
including a bunch of people they have
pricing for but no connection to or
maybe they're just flat out wrong and
they just made some of it up i mean
maybe ivan on tech sent a few lawyers
their way we have no idea again we have
to go back to the conundrum that
marketers often exaggerate and lie and
most of this info is coming from
marketers so that's really important
context here my point here is not even
to throw any individual influencer under
the bus right because some of this could
absolutely be wrong but just assuming
that even 50 of this is correct because
we know at least part of this list is
confirmed we just don't know how much so
even if 50 is correct what this shows is
that most of these influencers make what
a lot of people make in a year they make
it in a single post about crypto so my
goal in this video again not to call
anybody specifically out because how bad
they are really ranges right some people
say they're sponsored some people don't
some people promote super unethical
projects some people don't so that's not
the point instead the lesson is this we
should have all been crypto influencers
oh my gosh we made mistakes
no no i'm not actually i'm actually
kidding the actual lesson is this guys
when you see crypto advice online when
you see it coming from an influencer
maybe a rapper this is what you might be
seeing right there's stuff going on
behind the curtains and there's a very
real possibility that it's bought and
paid for and while we could hope that
these people would always do the right
thing and disclose that they got paid we
know that that isn't the case always so
uh just be safe out there it's really
easy to be greedy with everybody talking
about how they got rich from crypto but
bear in mind that a lot of the people
talking about it are actually getting
rich from promoting crypto not actually
investing in it thanks for watching see
you next time
what a shame what a shame you're a fraud
are you the same as sure you're saying
no you're not